cool alright thanks everybody for being
here this morning so I thought I would
start by just it's not working anymore
that's great
hello okay I'll do with that that's fine
so again I thought I will start and it's
not working either
Wow all right let me try something and
then again and then maybe that then yes
all right cool so I want to share the
link to the slides just because if you
want to follow along if I'm going too
fast or if something is too small I
tried to use the biggest font size I
could fit and write color contrast but I
might I've missed something so if you
want to follow along this is the short
link that's right to like make it pretty
simple but so let's move on to the
actual topic so I want to start with a
pretty simple slide I would assume that
if you're here you kind of know what
these represent but just in case on the
left you have a laptop and on the right
you have a mobile phone and the reason
why I started with that is because I
want to talk about interaction I find
that very weird you have the internet
which is like this giant network where
you can access information anywhere by
almost anybody and we decide to interact
with it in like a small screen that's
like our phone or or our laptop and the
way we interact with it is that we had
to learn these new gestures like swiping
and and like tap it up on your you know
on your keyboard and it became part of
what we do and we accepted it and
personally I don't really believe in the
keyboard like that being around for is
that much longer I think that there's
probably other types of interaction that
are a lot more natural that we should
focus on and this is what I like to do
on my personal time so by day I'm a
software devs so I probably work on the
same type of stuff as you do just like
websites or apps and but on my personal
time I like to explore alternative inter
interactions so I like to kind of play
around with technology and see how I can
interact with stuff outside of the
typical keyboard and phone so let's talk
about these interactive technologies so
when you especially the new stuff you
can start with the wearables
you probably even are wearing a Fitbit
and if you think about the dashboard
that you get yes you have to interact
with it later on on your phone or on
your laptop but the whole tracking of
your steps is done quite freely like you
can move around and it will count you
don't actually have to hold your phone
and say like you know 1 step 2 step 3
steps
it's kind of it's free it kind of dicey
and you don't have to think about it and
then you have also voice your eyes some
of you probably have an Amazon echo or a
Google home or maybe any other device
that I don't know about but same thing
it's kind of it's a lot more free you
can move around your house and you just
have to say a certain comment and you
can access information without having to
be especially in front of a laptop or
having to take your phone out of your
pocket and I think that's quite powerful
maybe it doesn't work you know as well
right now but I think it's really
important to be working on that kind of
interactions motion some of you might be
working in offices where you can just
walk around and the lights turn on and
same thing like if nobody is in the
office after a certain time the lights
turn off and you don't have to think
about it it's all around us but it's
kind of like disappearing this one is
quite funny like facial recognition and
computer vision I didn't know that but
in China you can pay at KFC with your
face I find that quite interesting
because I can't even imagine the
interaction that you go to the shop and
it's kind of like hi would you like to
pay by card cash or face today well I
pay by face thank you it's it's quite it
is I mean I don't really want to pay
with my face but they are already doing
it so maybe you know in a few years
we'll all have to do it and the one I
want to focus on today is biofeedback so
biofeedback is just having the data
coming like getting data of
physiological functions using devices
that track the activity of different
systems in the body and especially I'm
working with the Emotiv EPOC which is a
brain sensor and before talking about
how this sensor the device actually
works I thought we should go back to how
the brain actually works so I'm not
around neuroscientist so I can't explain
in depth how the brain actually works
and I don't think we really really know
but I'm gonna do like a very high level
and very brief intro so that we can
understand what's going on afterwards
so you start with a subject could be
anybody and with an intent of doing
something and it triggers a certain part
of the brain and different parts of the
brain are in control of different
activities and then the for example you
want let's say you want to walk so you
don't think about working you just kind
of do so you have a trigger in I think
actions are in the prefrontal cortex but
I don't actually remember exactly so but
then the this part of the brain is gonna
send a signal to a body part so that's a
ham because I was looking for an icon of
legs and it's either strongmen legs or a
sexy women links and I was like [ __ ]
this I'll just get it ham that's the
same thing and it's gender-neutral and
it's and yeah so and then so the the
part of the brain that's responsible for
actions of walking send a signal to your
little hams and you end up walking like
that ends up being an action so all it
does is basically just signals from the
brain to the rest of the body and so now
how does the emotive work so it has 14
different senses and on the left you
have where these channels are placed
around the head and in the middle you
have how a more kind of a high level
like high-definition brain sensor works
and in green and orange you have where
the emotive is placed around that so
they kind of try to cover a broad range
of the face on the on the head but
without having to have too many senses
and when I got this brain sensor I of
course I wanted to play with it but the
only thing available was an SDK in C++
and Java
I learned Ruby and JavaScript so I was a
bit like yeah that's not gonna work for
me but I didn't want to give up like
that's a piece of device that's quite
you know can be a bit expensive it's a
lot cheaper than something that you find
hospitals but it's still like a bit of
money so I didn't want to give up and so
I decided to try and build something in
JavaScript to allow other JavaScript
devs to not go through the struggles
that I went through and just being able
to buy the device and use javascript
with it so I built epic Jess that's
basically the r-spec framework that
you to interact with the data coming
from the brain sensor in JavaScript and
for the features so when you get this
sensor you can download what's called
the composer which is an emulator so you
don't have to actually set up the sensor
all the time you don't have to carry it
around it can be a bit fragile so you
can actually open the emulator write
your program and if you can send actions
from the emulator to your programming it
does what you want then your sweet it's
working but you can also have access to
the live data so the device has a
gyroscope and accelerometer so you can
get the head movements you can get
performance metrics so you can get your
level of focus excitement attention
stress you can also get facial
expressions with the sensors around the
black front of the face so for example
smiling or looking right looking left up
down and a few others but the most
exciting part is that you can get some
mental comments so they have to be
related to a thought of action and I
would assume but I'm not sure that it's
because it's easier to recognize as a
pattern then thinking about a chair or
something like that when you think about
an action I think the the signals that
come from the brain are easier to
recognize and like in different people
then thinking about the beach in terms
of text attack so I had to use the C++
SDK in the background
probably very badly written but it works
and then I created what we called
node.js add-on and I used these three
modules there so now I know that there's
a new way to create images I don't that
I think is called an API but at the time
when I started it it wasn't there so I
haven't updated it but for now it works
so when I get time I'll probably try to
like move over Oh No okay oh my god
alright so demo time I always like to
start my demos with a little reminder
that it might not work I it's supposed
to work it was working a few days ago
but
yeah all right so I was already nervous
but I see so the first thing that I
built is a brain keyboard so it's just
an interface of well a keyboard and I
wanted to be able to interact with it
just by moving my eyes so this demo is
not related to thoughts it's just like
facial actions and stuff so one before I
start so the little bit annoying thing
with the sensor is that you have to put
some kind of gel on all of them to
conduct properly so I did it before the
talk to make sure that I'll be fine but
I'll just redo it quickly because it's
better if it's well connected it's not
that much of a pain but it's just a
little bit all right I should be alright
and okay so the thing is you do look
stupid when you're wearing so just get
used to it alright so as its demo you
might want to take a picture which is
fine and I forgot I don't know if I turn
it on enough okay I don't know so you
might want to take a picture which is
fine just make sure my eyes are open
because I already look stupid so if my
eyes are closed on top of that I'd be
like so don't take a picture
I heard don't take a picture when my
eyes are closed
please like that's already quite hard so
okay so I'm here and then I have okay
let me check something first I want to
check if it's green everywhere so I have
to launch another of another one of
their program oh I'm missing one here
yes oh hello
oh it was wait was it on so I did turn
it on
that's interesting okay so that's not
great but it it should be alright let's
try so I have my server and I just have
no Optus
okay so if I look right yes and I blink
blink it doesn't get the blink so I'll
cry and or did look left okay right
blink left damn all right okay let me
try a bit more oh well I did wink but
yes okay so right okay blink blink blink
no okay
well that's working really well doesn't
it I knew it
it's letting me down all the time why
you I know I'm moving my well now you
want to work alright so well that's the
point I supposed to be working fine but
it doesn't so I'm gonna move on to the
other day mode I know hopefully this one
is actually gonna work a bit better
probably not but so the other demo that
I built
so the aim at the end is to have mine
controlling when VR so I'm aware that's
not totally what VR is just a 3d in the
browser but that's ice I'm pretty sure
that it's gonna let me down I just
recorded something so that I have the
proof that it actually does work so the
I for now I just trained the thoughts of
thinking about the direction right left
pushing and pooling so I'll try and kind
of like go back and forth so let's see
the thing is well is that you have to
focus quite a lot and my state oh I need
to top that one yeah we're still
tracking and my yeah the state of mind I
mean right now is I'm not really I'm
thinking about other stuff I'm thinking
about I'm like nervous
okay so server again and then again I'll
go to localhost
man yes okay yeah okay yeah go back man
I'm struggling
it doesn't want to go right but that's
fine let me try again I'll try again
I'll try again
okay maybe I need to missing some into
me okay I don't have time to redo it all
right
I really want to go right okay
yeah okay well I went right all right oh
[Applause]
well all right so I'm gonna take that
off because well now I have see a little
bit my hair this is great
forget about having a cool haircut all
right so what is next
okay code samples just to show you very
quickly how it works this is a very very
short code sample there's more lines
than that I try to make it a quite big
so if we start from just take it as
pseudocode because there's a lot of code
missing so it's just about understanding
the process of like the node.js module
so at the bottom you want to create a
module that we're gonna call module and
it's entry point is going to be the init
function and the init function is right
here and we're gonna create a function
that we want to be able to have access
to in JavaScript that we call that I
called connect to you emo composer and
so that when we require the module in
JavaScript were just going to be able to
call that to start the whole thing and
what this method is gonna do is that
it's actually gonna be connected to our
connect function that's here and what
this one does and this is where you use
the C++ SDK is you start by creating an
emo state handle that's gonna be
handling the data coming from the brain
sensor and you use you use that handle
to check if what kind of expressions you
get or what kind of thought you get so
for example if you want to know if
you're blinking it comes back as an
integer 0 1 so you keep checking and and
then we just have like a an object that
are called event and we have a property
we like I add a property blink on the
even object and the value of it is going
to be the integer coming back from
checking if I'm blinking or not so yeah
very poorly written I don't actually
know if he's fully eternal because I
don't do C++ but it works so that's fine
for me and then so this is like the C++
file and then you have the binding zip
file and same that's really sure it's
simple there's a bit more but basically
what it does is that you take the your
C++ file as the source file and you say
that the the target name is module
because it comes from my supercilious
file I just wanted to call it module
then
you build a table you compile and in
JavaScript you can require that module
and then we have access to connect to
emo composer and then we get our object
with the data coming back and I also
have connect to live data function where
you Pat you put in the path to the file
where you are recorded your brain
patterns and basically when you run the
program you have access to this object
with the properties blinking looking
right or looking left or whatever you
want so very quickly this is how it
actually works and in the end I'm just
like it's actually not that bad it took
me a while to figure it out because not
knowing C++ it was it was very hard to
even like know where I was going but in
the end I got there it definitely needs
to be factored but I didn't factor it a
few times I remember once I realized I
had two files of a few hundred lines and
they were actually doing exactly the
same thing so I could delete everything
I felt so productive it was awesome so
the limits of course you need training
for each user not for the facial
expressions but for the mental comments
which in a way is a good thing because
it means we would be exactly all the
same but it means that when when a user
trial act tries it for the first time
you do have to train it before being
able to use it you can't track
everything that kind of like makes sense
to me but sometimes you see people
complaining about like oh it's not good
enough you doesn't know what I want and
it's like its brain censor that you can
just buy online it already has like
around 15 actions that you can track
like what else do you want and latency
so as you have to focus and as it has to
like to check all the time the
difference between your current
brainwaves and the patterns that it
knows you do have a bit of a delay
between like you're thinking and you're
focusing and then it detects it so
depending on what you would like want to
build with it it might not be the right
thing if you want to be like a
controlled car you might not want to use
them but there's also limits in terms of
user experience I think the take is
actually quite cool but as users we'd
like to have a seamless interaction we
like to be able to use technology and we
want technology to do whatever we want
without having to even think about it
there's a bit of a limits in terms of
how we are building technology right now
you like a lot of the time as we build
in
vation and we think about it from a deaf
one of you like oh my god this
innovation is amazing but it actually
doesn't like people don't want to use it
like it won't work we have trust issues
with technology we when the new product
comes in we're super excited and we use
it but then it fails once and that's
over and we don't use anymore which is
also interesting and if you want to
develop products like that you also have
to think about that I think as user we
should probably be a bit more like nice
to tech because you have to remember
that we build it's not do this magical
thing that you just buy and it works and
real value so when if you would want
people to actually use new interactions
and stuff like the brain sensor you
really have to find a way to make it
like to make it bring value we kind of
like we have habits and we like to use
this habit because we don't have to
think so you have to make sure that what
you're building is actually good enough
for people to want to switch for example
if this even if this brain sensor was
like super powerful and it works really
well I'm not sure I will walk around
with our own I mean instead of like
social acceptance it's not it doesn't
really work but that's just like the
three points that I could think about
but I'm sure there's more because I was
kind of like researching interactions
and technology and this TED talk is
really cool because it's so this person
the students from MIT built a device
where you had a camera and a projector
and you could walk around and have
things projected on your environment
rather than having to take to your phone
or your iPad and things like that so you
could point to a newspaper and have
videos you know as if like you were in
Harry Potter or stuff like that and you
could make a gesture like this and you
would recognize it and take a picture
for you which I thought the cool was
like the tech was really cool and it
worked quite well in the demo at least
but then I scrolled down and I saw that
it was made 10 years ago and I was
surprised that I'm just like so now like
10 years ago
so we've like you know 10 years have
passed and we have nothing close to that
we are still using the exact same thing
and I find that quite crazy and at the
end of the talk the speaker actually
said oh we never know maybe in 10 years
we'll come back and we'll talk about the
ultimate brain implant and we are now 10
years you know
and we're not there at all so that's
quite interesting it sounded like you
have to figure out why exactly are we
not there and I think that we are
working so hard on making the tech good
that we forget to think about the user I
think we need to think about me like we
need to think more about people
possibilities accessibility of course my
demo is like small but I think it could
still be useful to some people you have
people working on trying to control a
wheelchair with that sensor I think
that's just like a uni project but
that's still pretty cool
mental health the Emotiv EPOC is not the
only brain sensor there's a few others
and they they have less sensors and they
usually focus on trying to make you deal
with stress and attention a bit better
so I think that's a cool space to also
have that I said like useful thing and
all right that's my favorite so I had to
put it in there
I like mixing technology and art because
you can explore things that you don't
get to do at work and it might seem
useless for some people but I would like
to remind everybody that useless is not
worthless a lot of the things that I do
are useless but I learned so much from
doing it and I learn stuff that I can
apply on all the projects and I'll even
like when I started with the brain
sensor I didn't want to do a brain
keyboard I was just thinking oh would it
be cool if I could have some graphics
with my brain and and then it ended up
being something that could be useful and
I and I learned a lot
so yes useless is definitely not
worthless I just wanted to quickly show
something else that I didn't build that
I thought would be like even the next
step that's even more incredible I don't
know if you have heard of project alter
ego so that's also MIT Media Lab and
this device can actually track internal
speech and translate into words so you
know when you talk to yourself in your
head so you you create the words like I
can hear myself talk in my head but they
managed to the manage to kind of sense
the electrical signals that happen in
your jaw when you think about speaking
and to translate that into words and
there's an interview where this student
could Google things and answer questions
by just kind of like thinking about the
words
so of course I'm sure they polish that
demo for the interview but it's like
it's amazing and I'm just like well you
know it's like probably like electrodes
or whatever I have electrodes at home
maybe I could just try it so maybe I'll
try but we'll see and I just wanted to
show quickly something funny is like the
first prototype of our ego was that and
it just reminded me of an Emotiv EPOC
but upside down and I was like well
maybe I'm sweet I couldn't just use that
you know and so I just have a feelings
I'm getting to the end of my talk but I
have a feelings if you want to have a
look that's probably a bit more that I
can add in there but if you are
interested in your technology there's
actually a slack channel that's global
where people talk about that and I
wanted to finish on that point you know
what sometimes you look at a piece of
art and you're like what the [ __ ] I
could have made this and this is exactly
how I want you to feel about that talk
because when you think about the tick
all I did is write some you know very
bad C++ and then I wrapped it up into no
chess add-on and the innovative piece of
tech is actually the sensor I didn't
make it I just bought it
and if I can do that I can assure you
that anybody here can do that all you
need to do is to maybe take a step back
and not try to think about making
something useful straight away just like
you know have fun you know like release
your inner child like don't be scared of
just trying and building something and I
can assure you that you're gonna have a
lot of fun doing this so this is the end
of my talk I am dev dev charlie on
Twitter you can of course always come
and talk to me if you want I'll be
walking around and if you have any
questions no worries unfortunately I
have to leave the conference this
afternoon because I have to take flights
or flights back to you Australia I have
to speak at another conference so I
won't be there tonight but I think I'll
leave maybe around 3:00 so I'll be
walking around if you have any question
thank you very much for listening and
thanks so much just one for you for
having me
[Music]